Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Olá e bem-vindo ao Resto e História. Comigo, o belo, grande Dominic Sandbrook,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如果你想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告连播、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告连播以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果你使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在 App 内订阅。您好，欢迎来到《历史的余烬》。我是英俊、高大的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），
e com meu criado, o jogador de cricket Tom Holland, que sempre fala sobre o cristianismo. Saudações a todos os nossos discípulos e seguidores. E uma saudação especial aos nossos amigos de Wolverhampton, os melhores futbolistas portugueses do mundo. Olá, Gonzalo Gues, olá, João Moutinho, olá, Mateus Nunes,
还有我的仆人、板球运动员、整天谈论基督教的汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）。向我们所有的信徒和追随者致意。特别向我们在伍尔弗汉普顿的朋友们致意，世界上最好的葡萄牙足球运动员。你好，贡萨洛·格德斯（Gonzalo Guedes）；你好，若昂·穆蒂尼奥（João Moutinho）；你好，马特乌斯·努内斯（Matheus Nunes），
olá, Ruben Neves, o capitão, nosso arroje. Tom Holland, I know you love a bit of Portuguese. I thought that was Dutch. No, no, no. That was absolutely pitch perfect, fluent Portuguese, Tom. And I'm sure our Portuguese listeners will be writing in to offer their congratulations.
你好，队长鲁本·内维斯（Ruben Neves），我们的骄傲。汤姆·霍兰德，我知道你挺喜欢葡萄牙语的。我以为那是荷兰语。不，不，不。汤姆，那是绝对完美、流利的葡萄牙语。我相信我们的葡萄牙听众会写信来表达他们的祝贺。
Was that Juga do Cricket? I heard. Nothing else to know, is there? It's actually worth doing this podcast purely for the pleasure of mangling continental languages, isn't it? So yesterday, Tom, we kicked off our history of Portugal, this sort of epic story that we're telling. And we got up to the death of Henry the Navigator.
我听到的是“板球运动员”吗？没什么别的要知道的了吧？实际上，仅仅是为了享受把欧洲大陆语言揉碎的乐趣，做这个 podcast 就完全值了，对吧？所以昨天，汤姆，我们开启了葡萄牙历史之旅，这是一段我们正在讲述的史诗般的故事。我们讲到了航海家亨利（Henry the Navigator）的逝世。
So the Portuguese, they've established this sort of medieval kingdom, one of many kingdoms on the Iberian Peninsula. They're not yet defining themselves against Spain. They have expanded to Madeira and the Azores, and they have this sort of sense of mission, don't they? So Henry the Navigator died in 1460, and that's seven years after the Turks have captured Constantinople. Rome really has finally fallen and Christendom is under attack.
所以葡萄牙人，他们建立了一种中世纪王国，这是伊比利利亚半岛上的众多王国之一。他们还没有将自己与西班牙对立起来。他们已经扩张到了马德拉群岛（Madeira）和亚速尔群岛（Azores），他们有一种使命感，不是吗？所以航海家亨利死于1460年，那是土耳其人攻陷君士坦丁堡的七年后。罗马最终真的沦陷了，基督教世界正受到攻击。
And I don't know about you, but I think that's hugely important in explaining the kind of militancy and the sense of mission that the Portuguese have in the next sort of 50 to 100 years or so, don't you? Though it obviously helps that it also makes them very rich. You're so cynical. Well, no, I think, I mean, we talked about that in the last episode, the way that, you know, the lust for spice fuses with a sense that this is what God wants. So Henry, the navigator, obviously he is fascinated and obsessed by exploration. But he is also the grandmaster of the military order of Christ, which is a successor to the Knights Templar, the kind of Christian militancy conviction that God wants you to go out and grab things from Muslims explains why today's story, which is the story of Portugal's expansion down the coast of Africa and then into the Indian Ocean, is a bloody as well as a heroic story. Yeah, it's interesting, isn't it? Because when you read this story, and I should sort of shout out, there's a book by Roger Crowley called Conquerors that I reviewed a few years ago for the Sunday Times,
我不知道你怎么想，但我认为这对于解释葡萄牙人在接下来的五十年到一百年左右所表现出的那种好战性和使命感至关重要，你不觉得吗？尽管这也让他们变得非常富有，这显然很有帮助。你太愤世嫉俗了。好吧，不，我认为，我的意思我们在上一集里谈到过，你知道，对香料的渴望与“这是上帝的意愿”这种信念融合在了一起。因此，航海家亨利显然对探险着迷。但他也是基督军事修士团（Military Order of Christ）的大团长，这是圣殿骑士团（Knights Templar）的继承者，那种认为上帝希望你走出去从穆斯林手中夺取东西的基督教好战信念，解释了为什么今天的故事——即葡萄牙沿非洲海岸向印度洋扩张的故事——既是一个血腥的故事，也是一个英雄的故事。是的，这很有趣，不是吗？因为当你读到这个故事时——我应该顺便提一下，罗杰·克劳利（Roger Crowley）写过一本书叫《征服者》（Conquerors），几年前我曾为《星期日泰晤士报》（Sunday Times）写过书评，
gave it a rave review actually, because I really enjoyed it. And he told it as an absolutely sort of rip-roaring, rollicking adventure story, although one completely soaked with blood. And it is one of these things where you sort of think there's so much fuss made about Columbus and about the conquistadors,
事实上还给了它极高的评价，因为我真的很喜欢它。他把它写成了一个绝对惊心动魄、跌宕起伏的冒险故事，尽管这个故事完全浸透了鲜血。这就是那种让你觉得人们对哥伦布和征服者（conquistadors）小题大做的情况，
but the Portuguese have sort of escaped all that because nobody really, you know, people don't speak Portuguese in Anglo-Saxon countries and they don't know what was happening. But there's an awful lot of terrible violence, isn't there? So Columbus venturing out into the vast emptiness of the Atlantic. know what was happening but there's an awful lot of of terrible violence isn't there so columbus venturing out into the the vast emptiness of the atlantic i mean you that is there's an inherent drama there but i think there is also an incredible drama in the idea of sailing down a landmass that
但葡萄牙人却似乎逃过了这一切，因为真的没有人……你知道，盎格鲁-撒克逊国家的人不讲葡萄牙语，他们不知道发生了什么。但这里面有大量可怕的暴力，不是吗？所以哥伦布冒险进入大西洋的茫茫虚空之中。知道发生了什么，但这里面有大量可怕的暴力，不是吗？所以哥伦布冒险进入大西洋的茫茫虚空之中。我的意思是，这其中存在着一种固有的戏剧性，但我认为，沿着一块你
you know nothing about you don't know what's what you're going to find there and the way in which when these expeditions start going down africa to try and get to India, they take with them these pillars, don't they? Stone pillars. Stone pillars. And they set them up in bays as kind of way markers. And I suppose you could say, well, you know, the vastness of the task. So all you can do is put one small stone pillar, the only mark that you can leave on the vastness of this, you know, strange lands full of strange creatures, strange peoples, strange plants. Yeah, it's a very kind of, and I think also that when thinking about this,
一无所知、不知道会发现什么的大陆航行，这种想法本身也具有难以置信的戏剧性。当这些远征队开始沿着非洲南下试图去往印度时，他们随身携带了这些柱子，不是吗？石柱。石柱。他们把它们竖立在海湾里作为某种路标。我想你可以说，面对如此浩大的任务，
because we know what's going to happen, because we know the brutal history that's going to follow, and we know that the Portuguese make it, and we know that in the long run, Europe is going to expand its hegemony across the world. We need to park that and think that Portugal is a tiny peripheral power and the sheer kind of boldness and daring of what they're attempting you know you have to keep that in mind if you're going to have a sense of just how extraordinary a story this is yeah i think that's absolutely right so so henry the navigator died in 1460 and the guy who takes over the sort of mission ultimately is um his great nephew who is Zhao Prince Zhao who
因为我们知道接下来会发生什么，因为我们知道随之而来的残酷历史，我们知道葡萄牙人成功了，我们知道从长远来看，欧洲将其霸权扩大到了全世界。我们需要把这些暂且搁置，并记住葡萄牙只是一个微小的边缘强国，他们所尝试的事情具有纯粹的胆识和勇气，如果你想理解这是一个多么非凡的故事，你就必须牢记这一点。是的，我认为完全正确。所以，航海家亨利死于1460年，最终接手这一使命的人是他的曾孙若昂王子（Prince João），他
becomes the king of Portugal in 1481 and he's a sort of very melancholy sort of lugubrious fellow kind of long-faced isn't he he's got a very long face a black beard um the Portuguese remember him apparently as the perfect prince and um Isabel i read that isabella queen of castile called him simply the man presumably she called him el hombre because he was such an impressive fellow so he basically has this desire like him with the navigator to be rich but he also is very into the prester john thing so the idea that there's a christian kingdom out there that they can make an alliance with against the islamic And also, crucially, to find a route to the Indies to get the spices. And what's funny is he turns down Columbus.
在1481年成为了葡萄牙国王。他是一个非常忧郁、阴郁的人，有点长脸，不是吗？他有一张很长的脸，留着黑胡子。葡萄牙人显然把他记作“完美王子”。我读到卡斯蒂利亚女王伊莎贝拉简单地称他为“那个人”（the man），想必她称他为“El Hombre”，因为他是一个如此令人印象深刻的人。所以他基本上有着和航海家亨利一样的渴望——变得富有，但他也对“普雷斯特·约翰”（Prester John）的故事非常感兴趣，也就是认为海外存在一个可以与之结盟共同对抗伊斯兰教的基督教王国。而且至关重要的是，要找到一条通往印度以获取香料的航线。有趣的是，他拒绝了哥伦布。
I mean, actually, the funny thing is people always tell that story and they say, the Portuguese were Muppets. They turned down Columbus. Of course, they were quite right. Columbus says, I can go west and find the Indies. And they say, yeah, don't bother me. Good luck. We're going to go our way. And indies and they said yeah don't bother me yeah good luck we're gonna go our way which we and we'll get and they do get that i mean they weren't wrong well when in due course um vasco to go does get to india uh manuel who succeeds jow he doesn't he
我的意思是，事实上，有趣的是人们总是讲这个故事，并说葡萄牙人真是个笨蛋。他们拒绝了哥伦布。当然，他们完全是对的。哥伦布说：“我可以向西走，找到印度。”他们说：“去去，别烦我。祝你好运。我们要走自己的路。”并且去往印度，他们说：“去去，别烦我。祝你好运。我们要走自己的路。”我们将会，并且他们确实得到了——我的意思是他们并没有错。好吧，当达·伽马（Vasco da Gama）适时到达印度时，继位若昂的曼努埃尔（Manuel），他没有——
he writes yeah he writes to ferdinand and isabella and says um you know he describes all the stuff that they found in India. So all the cinnamon, the cloves, the ginger, the nutmegs, the pepper, the diamonds, the rubies, everything. And he says, we are aware that your highness will hear of these things with much pleasure and satisfaction.
他写信——他写信给斐迪南和伊莎贝拉，说，“你知道，他描述了他们在印度发现的所有东西。”所有这些肉桂、丁香、生姜、肉豆蔻、胡椒、钻石、红宝石，应有尽有。他说，“我们知道，殿下听到这些一定会感到无比的高兴和满意。”
Which I think is splendid behavior. That's like the way you behave to rival history podcasters tom isn't it yeah it is well we all share we all take pleasure in each other's successes of course we do of course we do so so the first guy they send is um this guy diogo cow and he goes down to i mean he he goes a hell of a long way i have to say he goes to the congo he sales a bit up the con Congo, he sails a bit up the Congo, and he actually leaves a pillar there that's not discovered for another few hundred years. Yeah, so he's dropping off these pillars everywhere. Angola, Namibia. I mean,
我认为这真是绝妙的举动。汤姆，这就像你对待竞争对手的历史播客的方式一样，对吧？是的，确实如此。我们都分享——我们当然都为彼此的成功感到高兴。我们当然会的。所以，他们派出的第一个人是这个叫迪奥戈·康（Diogo Cão）的人，他一直南下——我的意思是，他走了极其漫长的路程，我必须得说，他去了刚果，他顺着刚果河航行了一段，
Namibia, that's a colossal journey. It's such a long way, and we know so little about him. So actually, that's the case with some of his successors as well. So they're sort of, they sail for 500 miles up the Senegal River. They go up the Gambia. They're crossing the desert. They're going to Timbuktu. So the Portuguese are convinced that they can find the route to India. And also they can find this guy, Preston John.
纳米比亚，那是一段极其漫长的旅程。关于他，我们知之甚少。实际上，他的某些继任者也是如此。所以他们，他们沿着塞内加尔河航行了500英里。他们逆冈比亚河而上。他们穿越沙漠。他们前往廷巴克图。因此，葡萄牙人坚信他们能找到通往印度的航线。而且他们也能找到这个叫普雷斯特·约翰的人。
And also gold, the supply of gold yeah because they know there's gold out there somewhere i mean this is a bit like the spanish in the americas we all know the story of the spanish in america's i actually like the portuguese story better because it's so it's not so hackneyed is it we don't know so much about it i suppose so the last um the pillar that uh cow sets up is on black rocks where seals are basking. And then he turns back around. It's such a kind of powerful image. Yeah.
还有黄金，黄金的供应——是的，因为他们知道那里某处有黄金。我的意思是，这有点像美洲的西班牙人，我们都知道美洲西班牙人的故事。实际上我更喜欢葡萄牙人的故事，因为它没那么老套，不是吗？我们对它了解不多。我想是的。康竖立的最后一块石柱是在海豹栖息的黑石（Black Rocks）上。然后他折返了。这真是一个极具冲击力的画面。是的。
So the next guy is Bartholomew Diaz. Bartholomew Diaz, I think, would be how the Dutch would pronounce it. Bartholomew Diaz. That is how they say it, Tom. That is how they say it tom that is how they say it yeah i was once on a train by with uh it's a very strange story this i was going to barcelona and um i was sitting in the compartment opposite a couple uh the man had no legs and the woman had no arms oh i mean it was very they were a good team a Yeah. A very good team. And they were Portuguese. It was the first time I'd ever heard Portuguese people. And they had this sort of, at first I thought they were speaking Russian
所以下一个登场的是巴托洛米奥·迪亚士（Bartholomew Diaz）。巴托洛米奥·迪亚士，我想荷兰人会这样发音。巴托洛米奥·迪亚士。汤姆，他们就是这么叫的。他们就是这么叫的，汤姆。他们就是这么叫的。是的，我曾经和——这是一个非常奇怪的故事。我要去巴塞罗那，
because there were so many of the sort of shh and the sort of yow kind of sounds. And then I discovered they were talking Portuguese. And they said they could understand Spanish, but the Spanish couldn't understand them. Yeah, well. So that's my great linguistic insight for today's episode amazing amazing thank you for that anyway can we
我坐在一个车厢里，对面是一对夫妇。那个男人没有双腿，女人没有双手。哦，我的意思是，这非常……他们是一个很好的团队。一个非常好的团队。他们是葡萄牙人。那是我第一次听到葡萄牙人说话。他们有那种——起初我以为他们在说俄语，
get back to bartolomeo diash yeah so he leaves he's a knight he's in one of zhao's knights and and basically um zhao says to him off you go i'll give you two of these caravels now if you don't know what a caravel is tom gives a brilliant, brilliant excursion into naval technology. Yes, I did. In our previous podcast. Shallow bottoms. And crucially, Tom, what else have they got? They've got triangular sails.
因为有那么多类似“嘘”和“哟”的发音。后来我发现他们在说葡萄牙语。他们说他们能听懂西班牙语，但西班牙人听不懂他们。好吧，这就是我对今天这一集的高明语言学见解。太棒了，太棒了，谢谢你。不管怎样，我们能
Triangular sails. Exactly. Triangular sails. And what does that mean, Dominic? It means that they can do what they like with the wind. They can literally do what they like. Is that what it means? That's exactly what it means.
回到巴托洛米奥·迪亚士吗？好的，他出发了。他是一名骑士，是若昂的骑士之一。基本上，若昂对他说：“你出发吧，我给你两艘这种卡拉维尔帆船（caravels）。”汤姆，如果你不知道什么是卡拉维尔帆船，请做一次精彩绝伦的关于海军技术的科普。是的，我做过。在我们之前的播客里。浅底。而且至关重要的是，汤姆，他们还有什么？他们有三角帆。
I think that's – I learned that from NAM Roger, the great naval historian. He told me they were his precise words. Yeah. Right. So they set off. They set off in the summer of 1487. We know very little about Bartholomew Diaz. We don't even know when his expedition left,
三角帆。没错。三角帆。多米尼克，这意味着什么？这意味着他们可以随心所欲地利用风。他们真的可以随心所欲。是这个意思吗？完全是这个意思。
even though it's going to change the history of the world. And he takes his stone pillars, doesn't he? He takes his stone pillars. They love a stone pillar in Portugal. Can't get enough of them. They take them now when they go on holiday. Anyway, off they go. They go for months.
我想那是——我是从伟大海军历史学家纳姆·罗杰（NAM Roger）那里学来的。他告诉我，这就是他的原话。是的。好吧。所以他们出发了。他们在1487年夏天出发。我们对巴托洛米奥·迪亚士知之甚少。我们甚至不知道他的远征队是什么时候出发的，
And by Christmas, they're in about Namibia or so. They've been here for four months. And then they take this absolutely big – so basically the wind is against them, so they think they can't go any further south. And then they take – this is where our grasp of naval technology will come in very useful time to explain this. They take this radical decision. So basically instead of continuing to go south, they say,
尽管它将改变世界的历史。他带着他的石柱，不是吗？他带着他的石柱。葡萄牙人太喜欢石柱了。简直百看不厌。他们现在去度假时也带着。不管怎样，他们出发了。他们航行了几个月。
let's sail right out into the sea to the west into the nothingness because there basically the wind may kind of whip us around and take us in a big loop well because that's what happens north of the equator isn't it it is that the trade winds you you sail out you go down africa you sail out west into the atlantic and then the trade winds blow you back to portugal i knew you're on top of all this Portugal. I knew you were on top of all this, Tom. Yeah. I knew you were on top of all this. The rest is navigation.
到圣诞节时，他们大约到了纳米比亚一带。他们已经在海上航行了四个月了。然后他们做了一个非常重大的——基本上由于逆风，他们觉得自己不能再往南走了。然后他们做出了——这就是我们对海军技术的理解将发挥巨大作用的时候，解释一下这个。他们做出了一个激进的决定。所以基本上，他们没有继续向南航行，而是说：
That's what we will be called. I'm like, what's his name? Patrick O'Brien. It turned out, actually, that Patrick O'Brien, do you know the irony is, it turned out that he was making it all up. He didn't know anything about rope or ships. Well, there you go.
“让我们向西驶入茫茫大海的虚空中，因为在那里，风可能会把我们卷起来，让我们走一个大圈。”哦，因为赤道以北就是这样的情况，对吧？是的，信风——你扬帆起航，顺着非洲南下，向西驶入大西洋，然后信风把你吹回葡萄牙。我知道你对这一切都了如指掌，汤姆。是的。我知道你对这一切都了如指掌。这就是“余烬领航”（The Rest Is Navigation）。
No one would ever say that about this podcast. No, we know our navigation so anyway they take this massive loop out into the atlantic bartholomew diaz and his and his guys and then they turn around and they see these mountains and basically what's happened is they have been carried by the winds in this great loop around the Cape of Good Hope, and they have gone around the bottom of Africa. And they make landfall eventually on what's now the Eastern Cape. In Mussel Bay. Is that what it's called? Mussel.
这就是我们将要被称为的名字。我就像——那叫什么名字来着？帕特里克·奥布莱恩（Patrick O'Brien）。事实证明，实际上，帕特里克·奥布莱恩，你知道具有讽刺意味的是什么吗？事实证明他全都是瞎编的。他对绳索或船只一无所知。好吧，就是这样。
So it's Dutch for mussel. Oh, that's lovely. So you've got a bit of Portuguese, a bit of Dutch in this podcast. Not only do you get top naval technology, you get great European languages. It's like a university in itself. We're offering all kinds of modules. So anyway, they pitch up.
没有人会对这个播客这么说。不，我们精通航海。所以，他们在大西洋中画了一个巨大的圈，巴托洛米奥·迪亚士和他的船员们，然后他们掉头，看到了这些山脉。基本上发生的事情是，风力带着他们绕着好望角（Cape of Good Hope）画了一个大圈，他们绕过了非洲的最南端。他们最终在如今的东开普省（Eastern Cape）登陆。在莫塞尔贝（Mussel Bay）。是叫这个名字吗？Mussel（贻贝）。
The natives, they are not very keen, are they? Well, no. And they're right not to be keen, basically, because these kind of peculiar people with white skins and guns and a tendency to enslave you, I mean, I i think it's you don't want to hang around when they turn up well there's this sort of story when ds was taking in water close to the beach they sought to prevent him and when they pelted him with stones from a hill he killed one of them with the arrow of a crossbow yeah and that i suppose is the sort of test the template isn't
所以那是荷兰语里的“贻贝”。哦，太棒了。所以在这个播客里，你既能听到葡萄牙语，又能听到荷兰语。你不仅能了解顶级海军技术，还能接触到伟大的欧洲语言。这就像一所大学本身。我们提供各种各样的模块。不管怎样，他们靠岸了。
it because there's going to be an awful lot of killing people with crossbows and things in um yeah in this podcast. So then they, the Portuguese turn around and Bartholomew Diaz, they sail all the way back when they go around the Cape. Apparently they first called it the stormy Cape because it was very stormy. And King Zhao doesn't like that at all when they get back. And he says,
当地土著，他们可不太欢迎，不是吗？哦，是的。他们不欢迎也是对的，基本上，因为这些皮肤白皙、带着枪、还有奴役他人倾向的奇特家伙——我的意思是，我觉得当他们出现时，你可不想在附近逗留。有一个这样的故事：当迪亚士在海滩附近取水时，他们试图阻止他，当他们从山丘上向他投掷石块时，他用十字弓箭射死了一个人。是的，我想这是一种考验，一种模板，
you can't call it that because it's sort of too downbeat. Um, so they attend it to change it to the cape of good hope yeah because it promises holds out hope that then one day they'll they'll get to india and when they've gone around the cape of good hope they've left behind their supply ship which isn't a caravel so it doesn't have a flat bottom bottom dominic or triangular sail so it can't do what they've just done useless absolutely and and they find that it's absolutely it's been eaten up by worms it's rotten with worms and so they haul it onto the beach and they burn it and have a huge bonfire and then they sail back yeah so
因为接下来在这个播客里，会有大量用十字弓箭杀人之类的事情。所以他们，葡萄牙人掉头了，巴托洛米奥·迪亚士，他们绕过海角后一路航行回来。显然，他们最初把它叫做“风暴角”（Stormy Cape），因为那里风暴很大。当他们返回时，若昂国王对此很不满意，他说：
dubious behavior all around um they get back to lisbon in december 1488 they've been away for 16 months they've they've discovered more than a thousand miles of new coastline well discovered i mean the people who live there knew it was there. But the key thing is that they've discovered that you can round Africa. Yes. Which of course the Phoenicians knew and Herodotus reports it.
“你们不能叫这个名字，因为它太消极了。”所以他们把它改成了“好望角”，是的，因为它孕育着希望，总有一天他们会到达印度。当他们绕过好望角时，他们把补给船落在了后面。那不是一艘卡拉维尔帆船，所以它没有多米尼克你说的平底，也没有三角帆，所以它无法做到他们刚刚完成的事。一无是处，绝对的。他们发现它完全被虫子蛀了，被蛀虫毁了，于是他们把它拖上海滩烧毁，举行了一场盛大的篝火晚会，然后他们就航行回去了。是的，
So if he'd been reading his Herodotus, he would have known that. But there are other ways of finding out. And this is of course the best part of four years before Columbus. So this explains, this is one of the key reasons why the Portuguese think, well, what's the point in you heading out to the West? We've already found that we can get around Africa.
到处都是可疑的行为。他们在1488年12月回到里斯本，已经离开16个月了。他们发现了1000多英里从未见过的新海岸线。好吧，说“发现”——住在那里的人知道它在那儿。但关键是他们发现绕过非洲是可行的。是的。当然腓尼基人（Phoenicians）早就知道这一点，希罗多德（Herodotus）也有过报道。
Was this publicized or were the Portuguese keeping it to themselves? I think it's not immensely well publicized because I think there's an enormous amount of emerging rivalry, I guess, between the Portuguese on the one hand and Castile and Aragon on the other. Because, of course, up to this point, there's been no Spain. So the Portuguese are just one of many competing Iberian kingdoms. But with the marriage of Ferdinand and Isabella, you have this sort of big self-confidence
所以如果他读过希罗多德的书，他就会知道了。但还有其他方法可以发现。当然，这比哥伦布早了将近四年。所以这就解释了——这是葡萄牙人认为“你们向西航行有什么意义？我们已经发现我们可以绕过非洲了”的关键原因之一。
and the conquest of the Alhambra and granada so that's 1492 isn't it so the portuguese are aware that there's this big rival now and and there's a definite sense of competition i think from this point on was that wasn't really there before and the portuguese defining themselves against the spanish so it makes sense they would want to hold on to you Sometimes they want to trumpet it, to boast, but sometimes they want to kind of keep it to themselves. And that is the context for, in 1494, so two years after Columbus crosses the Atlantic,
这是公开的，还是葡萄牙人对此秘而不宣？我认为这并没有得到广泛的宣传，因为我认为一方面是葡萄牙，另一方面是卡斯蒂利亚和阿拉贡之间，出现了越来越多的竞争。因为当然，在此之前还没有西班牙。所以葡萄牙只是众多相互竞争的伊比利利亚王国之一。但随着斐迪南和伊莎贝拉的联姻，你拥有了这种强烈的自信，
the notorious Treaty of Tordesillas, when basically the Spanish and the Portuguese divide the world up between them. Yeah. And the Portuguese, I mean, people don't really know this, but the Portuguese trick the Spanish effectively. They send much better negotiators to Tordesillas and they basically fiddle with the original deal. So the deal was they're going to draw a vertical line down the world. And in very, very simplistic terms, the Spanish will get the western half and the Portuguese get the east. So the Portuguese have already gone east and they're going to get Africa and the Indies and
以及对阿尔罕布拉宫和格拉纳达的征服，那是1492年，对吧？所以葡萄牙人意识到现在有了一个巨大的竞争对手，从那时起，有一种明确的竞争感，而这在此之前并不真正存在。葡萄牙人将自己与西班牙人对立起来，所以他们想要把这些秘密保守起来是合情合理的。有时他们想大肆宣扬、吹嘘，但有时他们想把这当成秘密。这就是1494年的背景——在哥伦布横渡大西洋两年后，
so on. And the Spanish will get the west. But the Portuguese, they basically persuade the Spanish to agree to shift the line by a thousand miles to the west and if they hadn't done that they wouldn't have then been entitled to get Brazil and and so this is one of the reasons why people have argued that Portugal had already discovered Brazil by this point I don't think they'd discovered Brazil at this point but we've been describing how Portuguese ships are starting to veer out westwards yeah and ride the winds so i think it's not beyond the bounds of possibility that they might have yeah it's possible something out there it's possible who knows i mean they don't they don't settle brazil they don't really colonize brazil for another few decades yeah it's not their prime
臭名昭著的《托德西利亚斯条约》（Treaty of Tordesillas）签订了，当时西班牙和葡萄牙基本上瓜分了世界。是的。而且葡萄牙人——人们其实并不知道这一点，但葡萄牙人实际上愚弄了西班牙人。他们派出了好得多的谈判代表去托德西利亚斯，他们基本上篡改了最初的协议。所以协议是他们要在世界上画一条垂直线。用非常非常简单的话说，西班牙将获得西部，葡萄牙获得东部。所以葡萄牙已经向东进发，他们将获得非洲、印度等等。而西班牙将获得西部。但葡萄牙人基本上说服西班牙人同意将这条线向西移动一千英里，如果他们没有这样做，他们就没有资格获得巴西。这就是为什么有人认为葡萄牙到这个时候已经发现了巴西。我不认为他们到这个时候已经发现了巴西，但我们一直在描述葡萄牙船只如何开始向西偏航，
objective is it no because they're still thinking about presto john, spices. And India. And India and Islam. They're still absolutely all about that. And actually, the year after the Treaty of Tordesillas, where they've – I mean, this sort of carving up the world is pretty notional at this point because, I mean, all they've done is they've sent the odd sort of ship around. But they have this new king, Manuel. Manuel is the great nephew of Henry the Navigator. And he is very militant i mean he really has this profound sense of mission that we will grab the spice trade we
并乘风破浪，所以我觉得他们可能发现了某些东西并非完全不可能。是的，这是可能的，谁知道呢？我的意思是，他们没有定居巴西，他们并没有真正在几十年内殖民巴西。是的，这不是他们的首要目标，对吧？不，因为他们仍然想着普雷斯特·约翰、香料。还有印度。还有印度和伊斯兰教。他们依然一门心思扑在这上面。事实上，就在《托德西利亚斯条约》签订的第二年，他们——我的意思是，在这一点上，这种对世界的瓜分很大程度上还只是名义上的，因为——我的意思是，他们所做的只是偶尔派一艘船四处看看。但他们有了一位新国王——曼努埃尔。曼努埃尔是航海家亨利的曾孙。他是个极具好战精神的人——我的意思是，他确实有着深刻的使命感，即我们将夺取香料贸易，
will destroy islam you know we've shown we can get around africa let's let's let's get it on you know let's let's go for it and And coincidentally destroy Venice as well. I mean, yes, because the Venetians obviously have- Yeah, undercut Venice. So actually, when you think about it, 50, 60 years before, Portugal is a nothing. It is a minnow on the absolute fringe. And now it's dividing the world up. And now, because of these splendid ships,
我们将摧毁伊斯兰教。你知道，我们已经证明了我们可以绕过非洲，让我们——让我们大干一场吧，你知道，让我们全力以赴。顺便连威尼斯一起摧毁。我的意思是，是的，因为威尼斯人显然有——是的，抢占威尼斯。所以实际上，当你仔细想想，五六十年前，葡萄牙什么都不是。它只是边缘地带的一个小不点。而现在它正在瓜分世界。现在，由于这些壮丽的船只，
their ambitions really are pretty boundless. And it's at this point that you know the guy that he turns to is probably the most famous of all these portuguese characters and that is vasco de gama so i think we should take a break and when we come back we should tell the extraordinary but bloody story of vasco de gama's voyage to india so we'll see you after the break see you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
他们的野心确实是无边无际的。正是在这个时候，你知道，他求助的人可能是所有这些葡萄牙人物中最著名的一个，那就是瓦斯科·达·伽马。所以我想我们应该休息一下，回来后，我们应该讲述瓦斯科·达·伽马前往印度的非凡而血腥的故事。我们休息后见。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这里有你每周的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和优先购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestis of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com bold in action severe in his orders and very formidable in his anger that is a contemporary description of vasco de gama, Dominic. As you said before the break, the most famous figure in the extraordinary story of Portugal's discovery of the world. And he is, I mean, so he's chosen by Manuel, this king who kind of presides over the golden age, really, of Portuguese expansion. And Vasco da Gama is the man who will finally achieve this dream
那是 therestis of the entertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。行事大胆、命令严厉、雷霆大怒——这是对瓦斯科·达·伽马的当代描述，多米尼克。正如你在中场休息前所说，这是葡萄牙发现世界这一非凡故事中最著名的人物。他就是——我的意思是，他被曼努埃尔选中，这位国王可以说是主持了葡萄牙扩张的黄金时代。而瓦斯科·达·伽马正是那个最终实现这一梦想的人，
that's been haunting Portugal's leaders since the time of Henry the Navigator of how do you get, is it possible to get to India going around Africa? Yeah, so Vasco da Gama is a very hard man, I think it's fair to say. Again, like Bartholomew Diaz, we don't know much about him. There are very few records of his early life. We know that he's probably from minor nobility and that he's been sort of doing piracy and sort of corsair behavior. He doesn't seem a pleasant man, does he? No, he's not a bundle of laughs, I think it's fair to say. He's the hard man of Portuguese expansion. I mean to say he's the hard man of portuguese expansion and um i mean if
这个梦想自航海家亨利时代以来一直萦绕在葡萄牙领导人的心头：绕过非洲去印度是否可行？是的，所以瓦斯科·达·伽马是个狠角色，我认为这样说很公平。和巴托洛米奥·迪亚士一样，我们对他的了解不多。关于他早年生活的记录非常少。我们知道他可能来自小贵族家庭，曾从事海盗和私掠活动。他看起来不像个讨人喜欢的人，对吧？不，我认为公平地说，他不是个让人开心的家伙。他是葡萄牙扩张中的狠角色。我的意思是说他是葡萄牙扩张中的狠角色，
you're the hard man of portuguese expansion you're pretty hard he's not a man who would who would sit of an evening enjoying a glass of port and listening to some lovely fado music no that's fair to say isn't it tom i think he'd be out crushing heads and mastering people burning them firing grassbows at people and grabbing diamonds yeah he would indeed so um and i think he's chosen because you know because of his hardness he's not chosen because he's a great seafarer or a cartographer or something you know the portuguese absolutely know what they're they're getting into but what's really interesting and what is nice for you because i know you enjoy a nice bit of of Christianity, is they sail from a place that is now known as Belang, so Bethlehem.
而且——如果你是葡萄牙扩张中的狠角色，那你确实够狠的。他可不是那种会在傍晚坐着享用一杯波特酒、听听美妙法多（fado）音乐的人。汤姆，这样说很公平吧？我想他会出去砸碎别人的脑袋、征服别人、烧死他们、用十字弓向人们射箭、抢夺钻石。是的，他确实会这样。所以——我想他之所以被选中，是因为他的狠辣。他不是因为是个伟大的航海家或制图师才被选中的。你知道，葡萄牙人完全清楚他们卷入的是什么。但非常有趣的是——这对你来说很好，因为我知道你很喜欢基督教——他们从一个现在被称为贝伦（Belém）的地方起航，也就是伯利恒。
So it's in the sort of western side of Lisbon. It's a massive place for tourists to go, as we'll discuss later on when we talk about the monuments that were built after these great voyages. And they sail in, I think, four ships. So they're caracks, they're not caravels. They're bigger than caravels. So what's a carack, Dominic? So it's bigger than a caravel. I think that's the technical.
所以它在里斯本的西侧。这是一个游客必去的宏伟地方，正如我们稍后讨论这些伟大航海之后建造的纪念碑时所要谈到的那样。他们乘着——我想是四艘船出发。它们是克拉克帆船（caracks），而不是卡拉维尔帆船。它们比卡拉维尔帆船更大。多米尼克，什么是克拉克帆船？所以它比卡拉维尔帆船更大。我想这就是专业的解释。
Does it have more rope? I think it has more rope. I think it probably may well have also had triangular sails. I'd have to do a bit more close naval technological research. I'm glad you said that. There's a point at which we should stop drawing attention to our ignorance
它有更多的绳子吗？我想它有更多的绳子。我想它可能也装有三角帆。我得再做一点更深入的海军技术研究。我很高兴你这么说。我们在某个时候应该停止暴露我们的无知，
because people will stop listening. Or maybe they'd have stopped already. Stop talking about Carracks then. Carracks. Well, they're in Carracks. I think it's very important to say they're in Carracks. Listen, what's interesting for you
因为人们会停止收听。或者也许他们已经不听了。那就别再谈论克拉克帆船了。克拉克帆船。好吧，他们乘坐的是克拉克帆船。我认为强调他们乘坐的是克拉克帆船非常重要。听着，对你来说有趣的是，
is that they leave in this atmosphere of intense religious passion. And they're named after the archangels, aren't they? The ships. They are. The ships are named after the archangels. And if you read, so I mentioned Roger Crowley's book, Conqueror is an amazing book. And he has this fantastic set piece.
他们是在这种强烈的宗教热情氛围中出发的。这些船都是以大天使的名字命名的，不是吗？是的。这些船都是以大天使的名字命名的。如果你读过——我提到过罗杰·克劳利的书《征服者》是一本极好的书。他写了一段精彩绝伦的重头戏。
They leave on a Saturday, the 8th of July, 1497. And the huge crowds come out of Lisbon to see them go. Vasco da Gama leads them from the church down to the beach and they're all wearing special tunics and carrying candles and people singing hymns and chanting the litany. And when they get to the water, there's a complete sort of dead silence and everybody kneels and makes their confession and they receive absolution.
他们在1497年7月8日星期六出发。里斯本的巨大人群涌上街头为他们送行。瓦斯科·达·伽马率领他们从教堂走向海滩，他们都穿着特殊的长袍，手持蜡烛，人们唱着赞美诗，吟诵着连祷文。当他们到达水边时，现场一片死一般的寂静，所有人都跪下做忏悔，并接受赦免。
So Henry the Navigator has received, you know, they hark back to the permission he got from the Pope for them to go off and kind of conquer the world. And they're all sobbing with religious ecstasy. And then they get on their boats and off they go. In their carracks. In their carracks, yeah. Let's gloss over the carracks from now on.
因此，航海家亨利已经得到了——你知道，他们回想起他从教皇那里得到的批准，让他们去征服世界。他们都因宗教狂热而泣不成声。然后他们登上小船出发了。乘着克拉克帆船。乘着克拉克帆船，是的。从现在开始我们对克拉克帆船一笔带过吧。
So it's an enormous, enormous voyage. So to just read from Roger Crowley's book, he says, For Vasco da Gama's men, it was an unending nightmare of back-breaking work, wormy food, foul water, terrible hygiene, and appalling weather. By the time they'd rounded the Cape of Good Hope and reached the Zambezi, many were dying of scurvy, their hands and feet grotesquely swollen
所以这是一场规模空前、极其漫长的航行。引述罗杰·克劳利书中的话，他说：“对瓦斯科·达·伽马的人民来说，这是一场永无止境的噩梦：筋疲力尽的工作、生虫的食物、发臭的水、糟糕的卫生条件以及恶劣的天气。”当他们绕过好望角到达赞比西河时，许多人死于坏血病，他们的手脚肿得变形，
their breath intolerably fetid their gums bloody and putrid so i mean we did a couple of podcasts well we did a series of podcasts on holidays this is not a holiday no you would so they get to by march 1498 so they've been gone for just under a year. They've got to Mozambique and then they go up the eastern coast of Africa. They get to Mombasa, Malindi in Kenya. And then they kind of cut across, didn't they? Because the Monsumians are in their favor. But I mean, that's an amazing thing though, Tom, isn't it? I mean, we're talking about Bartholomew Diaz making his big loop. I mean, this turning, you know, turning, I i guess to their right and heading out across the indian ocean i mean you've got no idea the sheer balls dominic yeah technical term they don't know
呼吸恶臭难闻，牙龈流血且腐烂。所以——我们做过几次播客——好吧，我们做过一系列关于度假的播客，这可不是度假。不，你会——所以他们到了1498年3月——他们已经离开将近一年了。他们到了莫桑比克，然后沿着非洲东海岸北上。他们到了蒙巴萨（Mombasa）、肯尼亚的马林迪（Malindi）。然后他们直接横渡了，不是吗？因为季风对他们有利。但我的意思是，汤姆，这真是一件了不起的事情，不是吗？我的意思是，我们之前谈到巴托洛米奥·迪亚士画了一个大圈。我的意思是，这次转向——你知道，向右转向，横渡印度洋——我的意思是，你根本不知道这需要纯粹的胆量，多米尼克。是的，专业术语。他们根本不知道自己要去哪里，
where they're going and they could easily have screwed up couldn't they if they got the wrong angle if the winds had changed they got you know they sailed at the wrong time so they sail for 23 days and more than 2 000 miles across this open sea and then they see mountains and lightning and stuff and it's the malabar coast yeah so this is um india this is sort of kerala isn't it yeah i mean you're you're more of an india hand than i am tom with your with your gap year in india and my many cricket tours yes uh was your gap year like this was that the same sense yeah wormy food foul foul weather, terrible hygiene. Exactly.
如果角度不对，如果风向改变，如果他们——你知道，在错误的时间起航，他们本可以轻易搞砸的，不是吗？所以他们在公海上航行了23天，超过2000英里，然后他们看到了山脉、闪电之类的内容，那是马拉巴尔海岸（Malabar Coast）。是的，这是——印度，这是喀拉拉邦（Kerala）一带，对吧？是的——比起我，你对印度更熟悉，汤姆，你曾去印度间隔年（gap year），而我有过很多次板球之旅。是的——你的间隔年也是这样的吗？也是这种感觉吗？是的，生虫的食物、恶劣的天气、糟糕的卫生条件。没错。
That's the cricket tours as well. Hands and feet grotesquely swollen. Yes, all that kind of stuff. That's very much what it was like. So they've been going now for 309 days. They've sailed for 12,000 miles, and they can glimpse the coast of India. And they basically get to the places called Calicut. And actually what happens is then a complete dam square because they get there. they can glimpse the coast of India. And they basically get to the place that's called Calicut.
板球之旅也是这样的。手脚肿得变形。是的，诸如此类的事情。情况确实差不多。所以他们现在已经航行了309天。他们航行了12,000英里，终于隐约看到了印度的海岸。他们基本上到达了一个叫卡利卡特（Calicut）的地方。实际情况是，那里简直是一片糟糕透顶的景象——他们隐约看到了印度的海岸。他们基本上到达了一个叫卡利卡特的地方。
And actually what happens is then a complete damscape because they get there. Then they get there and there's some Tunisians there. Yeah. So some people from North Africa. So they're like, oh, what are you doing here? And they're, hey! Which is utterly deflating for them. And they've brought all their richest treasures. And they give them to the uh
实际情况是，那里简直是一片糟糕透顶的景象，因为他们到了那里。然后他们到了那里，发现那里有一些突尼斯人。是的。还有一些来自北非的人。所以他们当时想：“哦，你们在这里干什么？”他们说：“嘿！”这对他们来说简直是沉重的打击。他们带来了所有最珍贵的宝物。他们把这些送给当地的——
to the local guy and he just laughs in their face doesn't he yeah it's terrible so they have um 12 pieces of i should read this from congress it's 12 pieces of striped cloth four scarlet hoods six hats four strings of coral six hand washing basins a case of sugar and two casks each of honey and oil and then they give them to the sort of local potentates guy. The guy says, the poorest merchant from Mecca or any other part of India gave more. And he says to Vasco de Gama, if you want to give a present, it should be gold. And he's utterly deflated. So there is bathos.
送给当地的头目。那家伙当面就笑话他们，不是吗？是的，太惨了。所以他们有——12件——我应该从《征服者》里读一下：12件条纹布，4件猩红风帽，6顶帽子，4串珊瑚，6个洗手盆，一箱糖，以及各两桶蜂蜜和油。然后他们把这些送给当地的权贵。那家伙说：“来自麦加或印度任何其他地方的最穷的商人都给得更多。”他对瓦斯科·达·伽马说：“如果你想送礼物，那应该是黄金。”他彻底受挫了。所以这里充满了滑稽突梯。
But, Dominic, how would you rate this as um a key moment in global history i think it's pretty big isn't it tom i mean it's some massive moments i mean the funny thing is of course there had been you know alexander the great had gone to india and people had traded with india hadn't they i mean we talked in cleopatra about how cleopatra had thought of fleeing to to india so roman traders are definitely doing it. But I think for Europe, it's a colossal moment. And in the long run for Asia as well. Yeah. I mean, for Asia, it's a bit like kind of opening your window
但是，多米尼克，你认为这是全球历史上的一个关键时刻吗？汤姆，我认为这相当重大，不是吗？我的意思是，这是个巨大的时刻。我的意思是，有趣的是，当然，以前也有过——亚历山大大帝曾去过印度，人们曾与印度进行过贸易，不是吗？我的意思是我们在《克里奥帕特拉》（Cleopatra）一集中谈到过克里奥帕特拉曾考虑过逃往印度，所以罗马商人绝对在这么做。但我认为对于欧洲来说，这是一个意义重大的时刻。从长远来看，对亚洲也是如此。是的。我的意思是，对亚洲来说，这有点像你打开窗户，
and suddenly a wasp flies in. I mean, they're small, but they're incredibly annoying. And they kind of buzz around and sting. We should stress that since the Portuguese are some of the smallest people in Europe, we should stress that you're actually talking about Europeans generally rather than the I am talking about Europeans generally. Although, let's carry on with the story. Because the story of, I mean, essentially, once the Portuguese have broken into the Indian
突然飞进来一只黄蜂。我的意思是，它们很小，但极其烦人。它们在周围嗡嗡叫并刺人。我们应该强调，既然葡萄牙人是欧洲体型最小的人群之一，我们应该强调你实际上是在泛指欧洲人，而不是——我确实在泛指欧洲人。不过，让我们继续讲这个故事。因为这个故事——我的意思是，本质上，一旦葡萄牙人闯入印度洋和太平洋，我的意思是，他们到处都是，不是吗？是的。谁也阻挡不了他们。所以瓦斯科·达·伽马在1499年9月返回。事实上，他有三分之二的船员死于坏血病、疾病，这个那个的。他们绝对是饱经风霜、痛苦不堪、衣衫褴褛。但他们确实带回了所有的香料。正是在那个时候，曼努埃尔给斐迪南和伊莎贝拉写了信。
and the Pacific, I mean, they're all over the place, aren't they? They are. There's no stopping them. So Vasco de G gets back in September of 1499. And actually, he has lost two thirds of his crew to sort of scurvy disease, you know, this, that and the other. They're absolutely sort of battered and miserable and bedraggled. But they do bring back all this all this spices. And that's when Manuel writes to Ferdinand and Isabella.
没错。没错。我的意思是，哥伦布给你带回了多少丁香？没错。因为这就是有趣的地方，你看。哥伦布没有带回他所希望的宝藏，这就是为什么斐迪南和伊莎贝拉经常问：“金子都在哪儿呢？
Exactly. Exactly. I mean, how many clothes has Columbus brought you? Exactly. Because that's the funny thing, you see. Columbus is not bringing back the treasures that he had hoped for, which is why Ferdinand and Isabella are constantly saying, where's all the gold?
你答应过的一切都在哪儿呢？”我的意思是，哥伦布直到死还在声称他已经到达了印度。他从不承认也从不相信自己犯了一个巨大的错误。而葡萄牙人则在暗自发笑。好吧，因为曼努埃尔——我的意思是，他确实大大充实了他的皇家头衔，不是吗？所以他一直是葡萄牙和阿尔加维（Algarve）的国王，他已经声称拥有非洲的一部分等等，但现在他宣称自己是埃塞俄比亚、阿拉伯、波斯和印度的征服、航行和商业之主，这把斐迪南和伊莎贝拉摆在了他们应有的位置上。对于西班牙人来说，这真是——
Where's everything you promised? I mean, Columbus died still claiming that he'd got to India. He never admitted and never believed that he'd made a terrible mistake. Whereas the Portuguese are kind of laughing. Well, because Manuel, I mean, he really beefs up his royal titles, doesn't he? So he's been king of Portugal and Algarve, and he's already claimed a bit of Africa and so on but now he claims to be lord of the conquest navigation and commerce of Ethiopia Arabia Persia and India which is putting Ferdinand and Isabella in their place exactly for the Spanish this is very um
你承诺的一切在哪里？我的意思是，哥伦布直到死时仍然坚称他已经到达了印度。他从未承认也从未相信自己犯了一个巨大的错误。而葡萄牙人则有点在笑。嗯，因为曼努埃尔，我的意思是，他真的强化了他的皇家头衔，不是吗？所以他一直是葡萄牙和阿尔加维的国王，他已经宣称拥有非洲的一部分等等，但现在他自称是埃塞俄比亚、阿拉伯、波斯和印度的征服、航海与商业之主，这正好让斐迪南和伊莎贝拉相形见绌，对于西班牙人来说，这真是嗯
this is enraging and as you say Tom for the next few years the Portuguese they send out expedition after expedition and actually these are often accompanied by horrendous violence specifically against muslims aren't they isn't it i mean so so that militant anti-islam is such an important part of the story yeah vasco de gama he makes three voyages in total i think it is and this i think it's his second voyage that they come across an Arab ship called the Miri, which is packed with pilgrims who have been going to Mecca. And basically Vasco da Gama, you know, he thinks it's his Christian duty. They captured 20 children and take them onto their boat,
这太让人气愤了，正如你所说，汤姆，在接下来的几年里，葡萄牙人一次又一次地派出远征队，而且实际上，这些远征队往往伴随着可怕的暴力，特别是针对穆斯林的暴力，对吧？我的意思是，这种激进的反伊斯兰情绪是这个故事中如此重要的一部分，是的，瓦斯科·达·伽马一共进行了三次航行，我想这是他的第二次航行，他们遇到了一艘名为“米里”号的阿拉伯船只，上面挤满了去麦加朝圣的朝圣者。基本上，瓦斯科·达·伽马，你知道，他认为这是他作为基督徒的责任。他们抓了20名儿童带到他们的船上，
forcibly convert them to Christianity, and then they basically burn the rest. Yeah. They set fire to the ship and down it goes. And Vasco da Gama thinks this is absolutely tremendous behavior. When he next goes back... Is that when he captures all the fishermen? Yes. He captures loads of fishermen.
强迫他们改信基督教，然后基本上烧死了其余的人。是的。他们放火烧了这艘船，船就沉了。瓦斯科·达·伽马认为这种行为绝对了不起。当他下次回去时……那是他抓捕所有渔民的时候吗？是的。他抓了大量的渔民。
He hangs them from his masts. And their families all come down to the beach because they hear that these Portuguese, very poorly behaved, have captured their relatives. And at this point, Vasco da Gama tells his gunners to fire in the crowd, to sort of shoot them down. And one of his men writes afterwards, seeing them cry, we jeered at them loudly, and the beach was soon cleared.
他把他们吊在桅杆上。他们的家人都来到海滩上，因为他们听说这些表现极差的葡萄牙人抓了他们的亲戚。就在这时，瓦斯科·达·伽马命令他的炮手向人群开火，把他们击倒。他的一名手下事后写道：“看到他们哭泣，我们大声嘲笑他们，海滩很快就被清空了。”
So there's absolutely no sense. I mean, maybe I'm being unfair here, but quite early on with the Spanish sort of conquest of the Americas, you get people. What's that guy, Tom, the priest Las Casas, you know, who are sort of breastfeeding about what they've seen in Cuba or in in Mexico or whatever. But you don't really get much of a sense of this from the people on Vasco da Gama's ships, do you? I mean, they're just absolutely delighted. Because as we said, Vasco da Gama is appointed because he is a brute, basically. And as far as I gather, his crews are essentially the kind of the sweepings of Lisbon jails. I mean, these are the most brutal men imaginable and kind of desperate, as I think you'd have to be to go on a kind of adventure into the unknown like that yeah um so yeah i mean that they are they are men who've been chosen because they
所以完全没有那种感觉。我的意思是，也许我这么说很不公平，但在西班牙征服美洲的早期，你就会发现一些人。那个家伙是谁，汤姆，神父拉斯·卡萨斯，你知道的，他们会对他们在古巴、墨西哥或其他地方看到的情景感到震惊。但在瓦斯科·达·伽马的船员身上，你真的感受不到这一点，对吧？我的意思是，他们只是感到绝对的高兴。因为正如我们所说，委任瓦斯科·达·伽马是因为他基本上是个野蛮人。据我所知，他的船员基本上都是里斯本监狱的扫地出门之徒。我的意思是，这些人是你能想象到的最残忍的人，而且有点绝望，我想你必须这样，才能踏上那种进入未知的冒险之旅，所以是的，我的意思是，他们是被挑选出来的人，因为他们
are brutal i mean there's also i mean it's in a brutal world isn't it because the portuguese see themselves they've been fighting against the north africans they they see themselves as in this sort of ideological hot war with islam they already have this practice with Muslims, what they call merdim boka, which I won't translate, where they do stuff to your mouth. But also they will shove pieces, take pieces and shove bacon fat down their throats and things. I mean, this is a violent world and the violence they're exporting to asia comes out of the sort of european theater i suppose and that's why it is so dangerous for them to go because you know they have no friends out there and it's not as if they're they're exactly making friends once they arrive there um and they and they just decide that violence is the way so they
很残忍。我的意思是，这也是一个残忍的世界，不是吗？因为葡萄牙人认为自己一直在与北非人作战，他们认为自己与伊斯兰教处于这种意识形态的热战中。他们对穆斯林已经有了一种做法，他们称之为merdim boka（我不会翻译这个词），他们会对你的嘴做一些事情。此外，他们还会塞进一些东西，拿来培根脂肪塞进他们的喉咙之类的。我的意思是，这是一个暴力的世界，他们输出到亚洲的暴力源于欧洲战场，我想这就是为什么他们去那里如此危险，因为你知道，他们在那里没有朋友，而且也不是说他们一到达那里就在那里交朋友，对吧，他们只是觉得暴力才是王道，所以他们
they intimidate you know they hang people um yeah menace people um but they also decide that and again i mean it's kind of very incredibly bold strategy that they're going to grab land and fortify it and make bases out and this becomes the start of a whole kind of network of portuguese bases that come to span the entire world. Yeah. So they said by 1503, they've got two. I mean, this is just within a few years of Bartholomew Diaz going around Africa, actually. They've got two toeholds in the Indian coast, so Kananore and Cochin. And then in 1509, Manuel, whose ambitions know no limit, I mean, he has written to the Pope and basically said, Christians may hope that shortly all the treachery and heresy of Islam will be abolished and the Christian faith will be spread throughout the whole world.
进行恐吓，你知道的，他们把人吊起来，是的，威胁人们，但他们也决定，再次强调，这是一种非常不可思议的大胆策略，他们要夺取土地，筑起防御工事，并建立基地，而这成为了整个葡萄牙基地网络的发端，这些基地最终遍布全世界。是的。因此，他们说，到1503年，他们已经有了两个据点。我的意思是，这距离巴托洛米奥·迪亚斯绕过非洲仅仅几年时间。他们在印度海岸拥有两个据点，即坎纳诺尔和科钦。然后在1509年，曼努埃尔（他的野心没有止境，他曾写信给教皇，基本上说，基督徒可以希望不久伊斯兰教的所有背信弃义和异端邪说将被废除，基督教信仰将传播到全世界）。
And he basically says to the Pope, I will deliver you, India. I will deliver you, Africa. And the weird thing is that Ferdinand has been saying exactly the same. So Ferdinand, as in Isabella, has been writing in identical terms. So both of them are basically saying, we're going to conquer the world. We're going to take all the loot. And this is great because it'll win us the Holy Sepulchre. Yeah.
他基本上对教皇说：“我将把印度交给你。我将把非洲交给你。”奇怪的是，斐迪南一直在说同样的话。所以斐迪南（指伊abella的丈夫）曾用完全相同的词汇写作。因此，他们两个基本上都在说：“我们要征服世界。我们要拿走所有的战利品。这太棒了，因为这能为我们赢得圣墓。”是的。
Because we think of the Crusades and the sort of the Age of Discovery is happening in different parts of history. We miss the fact that they really see themselves as crusaders, don't they? They think it's part of the same kind of continuum. And capturing Jerusalem is there. I mean, at the end of his life, Columbus is talking about expeditions to Jerusalem and all this.
因为我们认为十字军东征和地理大发现发生在历史的不同时期。我们忽略了这样一个事实，即他们真的认为自己是十字军，对吧？他们认为这是同一种延续的一部分。而占领耶路撒冷就在其中。我的意思是，在哥伦布一生的晚期，他一直在谈论对耶路撒冷的远征以及所有这些。
Yeah. So early 16th century, they're all over it. So there's this guy, Alfonso de Albuquerque. I hope I've pronounced that right um beautifully tom and he is the second european so there's been a previous one to be appointed a viceroy of india and won't be the last yeah i'm trying to remember the first one i think might have been called almeida and he's um albuquerque's number two but he's the most important because he is do you know what they call him tom you'd enjoy this the caesar of the east the portuguese mars he is a caesar isn't he because he goes around
是的。所以16世纪初，他们到处都在这样做。于是出现了一个叫阿方索·德·阿尔布开克的人。希望我发音准确，汤姆，太棒了，他是第二位被任命为印度总督的欧洲人（之前已经有一位了），而且不会是最后一位。是的，我在努力回想第一位，我想可能叫阿尔梅达，他是阿尔布开克的副手，但阿尔布开克才是最最重要的，因为他是——你知道人们怎么称呼他吗，汤姆？你会喜欢这个绰号的：东方凯撒，葡萄牙的战神。他确实是个凯撒，对吧？因为他到处
seating things very good very good so he grabs goa famous tourist destination now our lord has done great things for us because he wanted us to accomplish a deed so magnificent that it surpasses even what we have prayed for he boasts about burning the town killing everyone but we haven't spared the life of a single Muslim. We have herded them into the mosques and set them on fire. We have estimated the number of dead Muslim men and women at 6,000. It was, Sire, a very fine deed. So he's grabbed Goa. So that's adding to, so that's now three colonial possessions in India. Then they move on towards Malaysia. They capture Malacca in 1511. And this is astonishing. I mean, this is such a, you know, they're tiny.
占领东西。非常好，非常好！所以他夺取了果阿（现在著名的旅游胜地）：“我们的主为我们做了伟大的事，因为他要我们完成一项如此宏伟的功绩，以至于它甚至超过了我们所祈求的。”他吹嘘自己烧毁了小镇，杀死了所有人，“我们没有饶恕哪怕一个穆斯林的生命。我们把他们赶进清真寺并放火焚烧。我们估计被杀的穆斯林男女有6,000人。陛下，这是一场非常漂亮的战役。”所以他夺取了果阿。因此，这增加了——所以在印度的殖民地现在有三个了。然后他们向马来西亚进发。他们在1511年攻占了马六甲。这太惊人了。我的意思是，这真是，你知道的，他们太渺小了。
There are so few of them. And Malacca has what? I mean, it's 100,000 people, 120,000 people. Yeah. And they just kind of sail in and grab it. And they only have kind of a few hundred Portuguese. I mean, they have guns, crucially. But I think that the people in Mal mean they have guns crucially but i
他们人数太少了。而马六甲有多少人？我的意思是，有10万人，12万人。是的。他们就这样航行过去并夺取了它。而且他们只有几百名葡萄牙人。我的意思是，至关重要的是，他们有枪。但我觉得马六甲的人——我的意思是，至关重要的是他们有枪，但我
think that don't the people in malacca have guns as well they do but the portuguese they're just not prepared for the portuguese the violence of it the violence of the onslaught from the sea they're taken unawares but i mean this is um a cortez level victory against the odds it is and isn't it funny that uh unless you'd read i mean, I remember when I first read Roger Carrella's book, when I was reviewing it, I had never heard of Alfonso de Albuquerque. And he's within decades of the Portuguese setting out, just a couple of decades, basically. They've got as far as Malaysia and they're taking towns, establishing forts and colonies. He sends ambassadors to Burma, to Thailand, to Sumatra. He has ships that are mapping Eastern Indonesia.
觉得马六甲的人难道没有枪吗？他们有，但葡萄牙人——他们只是没有对葡萄牙人做好准备，那种暴力，来自海上的猛烈攻击让他们猝不及防。但我的意思是，这是一场逆境中的科尔蒂斯级别的胜利。确实如此，你不觉得很有趣吗？除非你读过——我记得我第一次读罗杰·克劳利的书时，在写书评的时候，我从未听说过阿方索·德·阿尔布开克。而他在葡萄牙人出发后的几十年内，基本上就短短几十年，就走到了马来西亚，占领城镇，建立堡垒和殖民地。他向缅甸、泰国、苏门答腊派遣使节。他的船只在绘制东印度群岛的地图。
He sends ships to Canton in China. And Duke Corsair grabbed Macau, didn't they? Macau, exactly, yes. It's not just the violence. It's also incredible kind of pioneering voyages. Amazing current, yeah. And they get to Japan, don't they? They found a colony in Nagasaki.
他派船去中国的广州。而科尔蒂斯夺取了澳门，对吧？澳门，没错，是的。这不仅仅是暴力。这也是令人难以置信的开创性航行。惊人的洋流，是的。他们还到达了日本，对吧？他们在长崎建立了一个殖民地。
They do, yeah, unbelievably. So a little bit later, 1543, they get to the southern bit of Japan, the first Europeans to reach there. And then they actually founded Nagasaki, the Jesuits, I think it was. Again, very little known in the kind of Anglo-Saxon world, but an astonishing sort of just the visionary scale of the achievement. Of course, one carried out with enormous violence. And since we've had so much violence, maybe we should have a tiny bit of,
确实如此，令人难以置信。所以稍微晚一点，在1543年，他们到达了日本南部，成为第一批到达那里的欧洲人。然后他们实际上建立了长崎，我想那是耶稣会士干的。同样，这在盎格鲁-撒克逊世界里鲜为人知，但这是一种令人惊叹的、具有远见卓识的成就规模。当然，这是一场伴随着巨大暴力的成就。既然我们已经经历了这么多的暴力，也许我们应该来一点——
well, it's still violent, but it's a bit of light relief. Because Albuquerque also sends back to Lisbon a white elephant and a white rhino and the right is the rhino is the one that um albert jura was without having seen it it's the first rhino to come to europe since the um since the time of the romans and the portuguese being the portuguese you know what they do with the they get them to lisbon and this huge crowd everyone's sorry and they say great now we'll like a child like a child saying who would win between a lion and a shark. Basically, their instinct is to say, now let's see who would win the fight. But the elephant runs away.
好吧，这仍然很暴力，但这是一点轻松的调剂。因为阿尔布开克还向里斯本运送了一头白象和一头白犀牛。犀牛就是阿尔布雷希特·丢勒在没有亲眼见过的情况下画的那头，它是自罗马时代以来第一头来到欧洲的犀牛。而葡萄牙人毕竟是葡萄牙人，你知道他们对它们做了什么吗？他们把它们弄到里斯本，这巨大的人群，每个人都很——抱歉，他们说：“太好了，现在我们——”就像一个小孩说：“狮子和鲨鱼打架谁会赢？”基本上，他们的直觉就是说：“现在让我们看看谁能在搏斗中获胜。”但大象逃跑了。
Well, it's very Roman behavior. Yes, it is. It's very, well, the elephant goes to Rome. It gets sent to the Pope, doesn't it? Yeah. So Manuel sends the white elephant to the Pope. And there's a huge, there's some Indians, there's parrots. It's a bit like a triumph, actually.
好吧，这真是非常罗马式的行为。是的，确实如此。这非常——大象去了罗马。它被送给教皇了，对吧？是的。所以曼努埃尔把白象送给了教皇。那里有许多印度人，还有鹦鹉。实际上这有点像一场凯旋式。
I mean, I wonder if that was in their mind. They had this huge parade through the streets of Rome. Because they're very alert to Pliny, who is describing the wealth of the world, and particularly the wealth of India. There's a huge kind of influence on them. So I'm sure that that must be lurking at the back of their minds this all this very roman behavior and the other roman behavior is that they build kind of great monuments they do i was just going to say you know but we're talking about the romans they call the the pope calls the elephant hanno which i believe is that is that is a hannibal um reference isn't it yes yes so hanno is a is a carthaginian name name. So it's an allusion to the Carthaginians.
我的意思是，我在想他们当时是不是这么想的。他们在罗马街头举行了盛大的游行。因为他们对老普林尼非常熟悉，普林尼描述了世界的财富，特别是印度的财富。这对他们有巨大的影响。所以我确信，在他们的脑海深处一定潜藏着所有这些非常罗马式的行为。另一种罗马式的行为是他们建造伟大的纪念碑。确实如此，我正要说呢，你知道的，既然我们在谈论罗马人，教皇把这头大象叫作“汉诺”（Hanno），我相信这是一个关于汉尼拔的典故，对吧？是的，是的。所以“汉诺”是一个迦太基名字。因此，这是对迦太基人的暗指。
But you were saying about the monuments, Tom. So by now, Lisbon is this, you know, which I suppose it wasn't exactly a backwater, but it's not one of the world's great cities before then. But now it definitely is. It's this incredibly colourful kind of entrepot of peoples and traders and ships and all kinds of stuff. Of course, lots of slaves because the slave markets are absolutely booming. And you were saying about monuments. So there are two very famous monuments. This is Manuel is the King, and it's what's called Manueline architecture. And if you want to see, if anybody hasn't been to Lisbon
但你刚才在说那些纪念碑，汤姆。所以到目前为止，里斯本已经成为了——你知道的，我猜它以前算不上什么偏远腹地，但在此之前它绝对不是世界上伟大的城市之一。但现在它绝对是了。这是一个色彩斑斓的人口、商人、船只和各种事物的集散地。当然，还有大量的奴隶，因为奴隶市场正在蓬勃发展。你刚才提到了纪念碑。这里有两个非常著名的纪念碑。当时曼努埃尔是国王，这就是所谓的“曼努埃尔式建筑”。如果你想去看——如果有人没有去过里斯本
and they want to go and they want to see the what kind of architecture you produce if you are incredibly self-confident and sort of puffed up with your own um your own glory then you go to beleng which is in the sort of western bits of lisbon it's where vasco de gama is set off from and it's where he's buried isn't it yes in the i think in the monastery yeah um so there are two very really famous buildings that are symbols of lisbon so one is that it's called the tower of belen which is this sort of fort sort of watchtower kind of building very ornate decorated with um the heads of the white rhinoceros and all these kinds of things so the classic kind of monument that you
并且想去看看，想看看如果你极度自信、因为自己的荣耀而洋洋得意时会建造什么样的建筑，那你就会去贝伦，它在里斯本的西部。那是瓦斯科·达·伽马出发的地方，也是他埋葬的地方，对吧？是的，我想是在修道院里。是的，所以有两个非常著名的建筑是里斯本的象征。一个是被称为“贝伦塔”的建筑，它是一座堡垒、瞭望塔式的建筑，非常华丽，装饰着白犀牛的头以及所有这些东西。所以这是你看到的里斯本象征的经典纪念碑。
see is a symbol of lisbon and the the other, which is even more impressive, is this monastery. The monastery, are they called the Hieronymites? They're called the Hieronymus in Lisbon. I don't know what the Hieronymites are. There must be an order of monks. But it's this massive monastery. Again, unbelievably ornate, the sort of gorgeous stonework. And it's that monastery, Tom,
而另一个更加令人印象深刻的就是这座修道院。这座修道院，它们叫热罗尼姆修道院吗？它们在里斯本被称为热罗尼姆修道院。我不知道热罗尼姆修士是什么。那一定是一个僧侣教团。但这是一座巨大的修道院。同样，极其华丽，有着华美的石雕。就是那座修道院，汤姆，
I know you like a bit of food and drink on this podcast where they invented the custard tart oh the famous portuguese custard tart so the pastiche to nato the pastiche to berlin which you can buy in this there's a very famous kind of cafe next to the monastery or just across the road from the monastery called the antiga cafetaria de berlin and there the custard tart, and actually Roger Crowley ends his book about the age of Vasco de Gama with the custard tarts, because he says they're basically a symbol. They are a symbol of Portuguese. Have they got coffee by the way? Because you have coffee with it, which is obviously an import, but they're dusted with cinnamon. And the cinnamon the the perfect symbol of what they've gone to india to get the spice trade so he says cinnamon sugar coffee that combination but they i mean they have they have
我知道你在这个播客里喜欢吃吃喝喝，他们在那里发明了蛋挞。哦，著名的葡萄牙蛋挞！所以帕斯泰尔·德·纳塔（Pastéis de nata），也就是贝伦蛋挞，你可以在那里买到。修道院旁边或修道院马路对面有一家非常著名的咖啡馆，叫贝伦古老咖啡馆（Antiga Confeitaria de Belém），那里的蛋挞——实际上，罗杰·克劳利在他关于瓦斯科·达·伽马时代的书的结尾处提到了蛋挞，因为他说它们基本上是一个象征。它们是葡萄牙的象征。顺便问一下，他们有咖啡吗？因为你吃这个要搭配咖啡，这显然是进口的，但它们上面撒了肉桂粉。而肉桂——它们去印度要找的香料贸易的完美象征。所以他说肉桂、糖、咖啡，这种组合。但他们——我的意思是，他们
gone to india for spice but they've also gone to india as part of a kind of global crusade against islam and to find prester john and presumably it wasn't there yeah Yeah. By this point, so what, 1520, say, they've realised Prester John isn't out there. Yeah. And so their focus now presumably is starting to turn just to trade. Yes, I think so. I mean, I think they also realise now that Islam is not going to be defeated overnight, certainly by the 1520s or 1530s. And also they're starting to... There's a point at they're starting to there's a point at where i guess
去印度是为了香料，但他们去印度也是为了针对伊斯兰教的全球十字军东征的一部分，为了寻找约翰长老，而据推测那里并没有。是的。到了这个时候，比如1520年左右，他们已经意识到约翰长老根本不在那里。是的。所以他们的重点现在据推测开始转向纯粹的贸易。是的，我想是的。我的意思是，我想他们现在也意识到，伊斯兰教不会在一夜之间被击败，特别是在1520年代或1530年代。而且他们也开始……在某个时候，他们开始……在某个时候，我猜
there's a point with all of these things with any empire builders where the focus sort of tips from exploring and the sort of the glamour to the sort of humdrum job of administering and the point is they're actually not very good at the latter so to what extent then is this empire as it emerges over the course of the 16th century a prototype for the european empires that will follow so that it's it's based on the seas which the dutch and the british empires will be as well and basically it seems to consist of establishing nodes across the world. Yeah. And then linking them up and using them as trade. And that's basically where the Dutch and the British will,
对于所有这些事情，对于任何帝国建立者来说，重点都会从探索和光环转向行政管理的平凡工作，关键是他们在后者上其实并不擅长。那么，在16世纪的进程中，这个帝国在多大程度上成为了随后欧洲帝国的原型？即它建立在海上，荷兰和英国帝国也将如此，基本上它似乎包括在世界各地建立节点。是的。然后将它们连接起来并用它们来进行贸易。而这基本上就是荷兰人、英国人后来会做的事情。
and the English and then the British will do as well. I think you're absolutely right, Tom. I think that's exactly what it is. So it's quite different, I think, in some ways from the Spanish empire, which sees large scale immigration from Spain. I mean, one reason they're able to overwhelm, you know, the Aztecs or the Incas is so many people arriving arriving but it's also land-based isn't it i mean i know they have to bring all the gold back in ships but it's not like i suppose the spanish are as well aren't they they're going they're getting the philippines and so on but they are but they're also they're
我认为你绝对是对的，汤姆。我认为这正是它的本质。因此，我认为它在某些方面与西班牙帝国有很大不同，西班牙帝国见证了来自西班牙的大规模移民。我的意思是，他们能够压倒（你知道的）阿兹特克人或印加人的原因之一就是有这么多的人到达。但这也是基于土地的，对吧？我的意思是，我知道他们必须用船把所有的黄金运回来，但它不像是——我猜西班牙人也是如此，对吧？他们正在获取菲律宾等等，但他们也是——但他们也是
expanding as you say by land and by sea i guess but also by land through the americas the portuguese are obviously not doing that in India. They're taking little coastal enclaves and using them as trading posts, but they're not settling abroad in huge numbers. I mean, obviously, we'll come to Brazil. I think we'll probably come to Brazil in our next episode because the great expansion into Brazil really doesn't happen until slightly later. But I think it's a very good well the dutch and the portuguese are absolutely implacable rivals and again we'll probably mention that next time we will yeah about this intense competition between
正如你所说，通过陆地和海洋在扩张，我想也是通过美洲的陆地在扩张。而葡萄牙人显然没有在印度这样做。他们占据着小的沿海飞地，并将它们用作贸易据点，但他们并没有大量移居海外。我的意思是，显然，我们会讲到巴西。我想我们很可能会在下一集中讲到巴西，因为对巴西的大规模扩张直到稍后才真正发生。但我认为这是一个非常好的——好吧，荷兰人和葡萄牙人是绝对不共戴天的死敌，同样，我们可能下次会提到这一点。我们会是的，关于
the dutch and the portuguese and actually at one point the dutch basically take over a lot of the portuguese empire and then the portuguese get it back again but yeah i think it's it's a really it's the prototype for the dutch empire i think and for aspects of the british empire um the portuguese empire i mean the portuguese are not good at running it so by the mid 16th century they're already you know there's endless governors fighting against each other i mean they're literally fighting against each other like the kings will send out governors who have to fight their predecessors to get hold of these sort of forts and trading stations. Brazil they go to in the 1530s, and obviously the slave trade starts to become a bigger and bigger issue.
荷兰人和葡萄牙人之间这种激烈的竞争，实际上在某个时期，荷兰人基本上接管了葡萄牙帝国的很大一部分，然后葡萄牙人又把它夺了回来。但是的，我认为这真的是荷兰帝国以及英国帝国某些方面的原型。葡萄牙帝国——我的意思是，葡萄牙人不擅长管理它。因此，到16世纪中叶，他们已经——你知道的，有无休止的总督互相争斗。我的意思是，他们实际上在互相争斗，就像国王会派出总督去与他们的前任战斗，以夺取这些堡垒和贸易站的控制权一样。他们在16世纪30年代去到了巴西，显然奴隶贸易开始成为一个越来越大的问题。
We'll probably talk about that next time. But there's a definite sense that by the mid-16 16th century there's a bit of a loss of momentum i would say and a loss of mission that the sense that basically the portuguese are inventing uh well a crucial aspect of modernity that they're blazing a path for globalization for european hegemony all this the slave trade um global, global trade, all these things that will utterly transform not just Europe, but the world. But in the mid 16th century, you have this kind of reversion back to the norm, where you have a King, King Sebastian, who basically behaves like a crusader. And he, rather than kind of focusing on distant lands,
我们可能会在下次讨论这个问题。但有一种明确的感觉，即到16世纪中叶，可以说有了一点势头的丧失和使命感的丧失，即葡萄牙人正在发明——嗯，现代性的一个至关重要方面，他们正在为全球化、欧洲霸权开拓道路，所有这些——奴隶贸易、全球贸易，所有这些将彻底改变不仅是欧洲，还有世界的事务。但在16世纪中叶，你看到了这种向常态的回归，你有一个国王，塞巴斯蒂安国王，他基本上像一个十字军一样行事。他没有把注意力集中在遥远的土地上，
he invades and attacks Mauritania, doesn't he? I suppose you could say King Sebastiao is where it all goes wrong for Portugal to some extent. So his, let me work this out, his great-grandfather was Manuel. And he succeeds when he's a boy, Sebastián, and his grandmother and then a cardinal run the country for him. Well, the cardinal is his uncle, isn't it? That's right, yes. And he's a crucial figure, and he is known as Enrique the Chaste.
而是入侵并攻击了毛里塔尼亚，对吧？我想你可以说塞巴斯蒂安国王在某种程度上是葡萄牙一切开始走向错误的地方。所以他的——让我想想，他的曾祖父是曼努埃尔。他在还是个孩子的时候继位，塞巴斯蒂安，他的祖母和一个枢机主教为他管理国家。嗯，那个枢机主教是他的叔叔，对吧？没错，是的。他是一个至关重要的人物，被称为“贞洁者恩里克”。
Well, that's pretty good for a cardinal, isn't it? Yeah, but this will become an important part of what then happens. Yes. Well, so Sebastien becomes, or Sebastiao in Portuguese, he comes of age in 1568. And I guess, I wonder whether there's a sense that Portugal's great glory days are already ebbing into the past. And so that makes him even more determined to sort of stake his own... To cut a dash. Yes own to cut a dash yes to cut a dash and he decides he's going to lead a crusade against the moroccans and he makes a terrible error tom which is to trust philip the second of spain who says to him rookies error yeah sure i'll
嗯，这对于一个枢机主教来说相当不错，对吧？是的，但这将成为随后发生的事情的重要组成部分。是的。好吧，所以塞巴斯蒂安——或者葡萄牙语中的塞巴斯蒂昂（Sebastião）——在1568年成年了。我想，我不知道人们是否有一种感觉，即葡萄牙辉煌的岁月已经退入过去。这使得他更加决心要确立自己的……展现一番风采。是的，展现一番风采，是的，展现一番风采，他决定领导一场针对摩洛哥人的十字军东征，他犯了一个可怕的错误，汤姆，那就是信任西班牙的腓力二世，后者对他说——新手的错误，对吧？当然，我会
send you supporters i'll send you know people to help you they all assemble all these troops and mercenaries they assemble at cadiz and the the Spanish are nowhere to be seen. All these promised Spanish reinforcements aren't there, but they go anyway, Sebastião and his men. So this is 1578. They cross the Mediterranean. They land in Morocco. And, I mean, you were in a previous episode, I think it was, Tom, you were complimenting the Crusades, but this is not a Crusade that goes, you said
派支持者去帮你，我会派（你知道的）人去帮你的。他们集结了所有的军队和雇佣兵，他们在加的斯集结，而西班牙人却不见踪影。所有这些承诺的西班牙增援部队都没有出现，但塞巴斯蒂昂和他的手下还是出发了。所以这是1578年。他们穿过地中海。他们在摩洛哥登陆。而且，你在前一集里——我想那是上一集，汤姆，你在赞美十字军东征，但这并不是一次进展顺利的十字军东征，你曾说过
some Crusades went better than others. This is one that doesn't go well. Doesn't go well, because in their very first battle, they're absolutely routed, absolutely routed. And he presumably dies. The last scene of him is he's charging the enemy, but his body is never found. So the mystery of what has happened to him, he leaves no heir. And so he is succeeded by his uncle, the Cardinal Enrique the Chaste. But by definition,
有些十字军东征比其他的要顺利。这不是一次进展顺利的东征。进展不顺利，因为在他们的第一场战斗中，他们就彻底溃败了，绝对彻底溃败了。而他大概也阵亡了。关于他的最后场景是他在冲向敌人，但他的尸体从未被找到。因此，关于他遭遇什么的谜团，他没有留下任何继承人。所以他的叔叔、贞洁者恩里克枢机主教继位了。但按定义，
if you're called the Chaste, you're unlikely, and you're kind of 60 or whatever, you're unlikely to be producing an heir. And so when Enrique the Chaste dies in 1580 the guy who is next in line for the throne is none other than philip the second of spain very much not a friend i think it's fair to say of the rest of his history philip the second of spain he hasn't appeared in this podcast before but now that he has i just want to absolutely state my colors to the mast and say not my favorite person not a fan well he's he's not he's not behaving well here um no and he he essentially well so he says about portugal i inherited it i bought it and i conquered it so yeah in every way he takes over although having said that i think we're doing philip the second
如果你被称为“贞洁者”，你就不太可能——而且你已经60岁左右了，你不太可能生下继承人。因此，当贞洁者恩里克于1580年去世时，王位的第一顺位继承人非西班牙的腓力二世莫属——我认为可以公平地说，他绝不是葡萄牙其余历史的朋友。西班牙的腓力二世，他以前没有出现在这个播客中，但现在他出现了，我只想明确表明我的立场，并说他不是我最喜欢的人，我不是他的粉丝。好吧，他在这里的表现确实不怎么样——不，他基本上——所以他关于葡萄牙曾说：“我继承了它，我买下了它，我征服了它。”所以是的，他在方方面面都接管了它。话虽如此，我觉得我们有点贬低腓力二世了，因为他的表现其实相当不错。我的意思是，他没有——他对葡萄牙保持了尊严，葡萄牙仍然——是的，你知道的，据称是一个独立的王国。而且事实上，汤姆，我们没有像本可以做的那样真正触及这一点，但此时西班牙本身是一个非常新的创造，（你知道的）西班牙本身就是一个由王国拼凑而成的国家，最明显的就是卡斯蒂利亚和阿拉贡。所以腓力二世只是又增加了一个王国。因此他未必会吞并它。因为我的意思是，他的前任查理五世统治着各种各样的地方，却没有把它们合并为一个。所以葡萄牙人（我认为可以说到目前为止他们已经有了对自己独特性的一种意识，这种独特性在过去的100年中由于他们自己的探索和任务而被锻造出来）根本无意成为西班牙人。这有点像苏格兰和英格兰，我想。要将它们结合起来将是非常困难的。类比的话，我猜是加泰罗尼亚，它同样对自己的独特性有着强烈的意识，被吸纳进将成为西班牙王国的实体中，并仍然是西班牙的一部分。但葡萄牙的不同之处在于——葡萄牙很可能也会发生同样的事情，但我想区别在于葡萄牙确实有这个——我的意思是，它拥有一个巨大的、属于葡萄牙的全球帝国。当我们进入
down because he does actually behave quite well i mean he doesn't he treats portugal with dignity portugal remains yeah you know supposedly an independent kingdom and i think actually tom we haven't really touched on this as much as we could have done but spain itself is a very recent creation at this point and you know spain is itself a patchwork of kingdoms isn't it obvious most obviously, Castile and Aragon. So Philip II is adding another kingdom. So he wouldn't necessarily absorb it. Because I mean, his predecessor, Charles V, had been ruling all kinds of different places without combining them into one. So the Portuguese, who already have, I think it's fair to say by now, a sense of their own
17世纪时，其他大国正在到来，新教大国以荷兰人为尖兵。而荷兰人开始用嫉妒的目光注视着所有这些葡萄牙领地。因此，西班牙君主国是否会帮助葡萄牙人对付这些（你知道的）荷兰海盗，正如葡萄牙人习惯于击退他们一样，
distinctiveness, which has been forged in the previous 100 years because of their own explorations and their own missions. They have no intention of becoming Spaniards. And it's a bit like Scotland and England, I suppose. It's going to be very difficult to combine them. The parallel is, I guess, with Catalonia, which similarly has a very strong sense of its distinctiveness, gets absorbed into what will become the kingdom of Spain and stays part of Spain. But the difference with Portugal, and the same thing might well have happened with Portugal, but I suppose the difference is that Portugal does have this, I mean, it has a vast global empire that is Portuguese. And as we enter
这对于葡萄牙是否会成为这个新兴王国的忠诚部分至关重要。因为葡萄牙人也觉得，我认为他们被拖入了这场针对荷兰的世界大战。是的。因为——因为他们被绑在了西班牙的战车上。是的。
the 17th century, so there are other powers that are arriving, Protestant powers of whom the Dutch are the cutting edge. And the Dutch start to look with envious eyes at all these Portuguese possessions. And so the question of whether the Spanish monarchy will help the Portuguese to see these, you know, these Dutch pirates as the Portuguese season helped see them off is,
而西班牙并不关心保护葡萄牙的领地。而对于葡萄牙人，你绝对能感觉到，我认为到17世纪初，葡萄牙因与西班牙联合而受到了不公正的待遇。我想正是在那个时候，你会开始发现——嗯，你在16世纪末肯定会发现所有这些冒名顶替者——那些基本上说（你知道的）“塞巴斯蒂安，那个冲向那些战线再也没有被看到的人，我就是他”的人。是的，尽管事实上我不会说葡萄牙语。其中一个人——嗯，有一个人是——所以第一个是一个普通平民。然后是一个来自亚速尔群岛的石匠。他显然不是——他受到了非常虐待。他被绞死了。
is crucial to whether Portugal will become a loyal part of this emergent kingdom. Cause also the Portuguese feel, I think that they've been dragged into this world war against the Dutch. Yeah. Because, because they're yoked to the Spanish. Yeah.
但难道不是那个完全不会说葡萄牙语的人吗？是的，他来自那不勒斯。他不会说——所以——是的。我认为这有点过分了——这非常像珀金·沃贝克和兰伯特·西姆内尔，不是吗？但基本上，很明显他已经死了，
And the Spanish don't care about protecting the Portuguese possessions. And the Portuguese, you definitely get the sense, I think, by the beginning of the 17th century, that Portugal has been hard done by in being sort of united with Spain. And I think it's at that point, isn't it, where you start to get, well, you definitely get at the end of the 16th century all of these imposters so people who basically say you know sebastian who was charging towards those lines and never seen again here i am yeah he's despite the fact i can't speak portuguese in one one of them well there's one of them who's um so the first one is a sort of a a guy who's is just an ordinary commoner. Then there's a guy who's a stonecutter from the Azores. He's obviously not – he's very poorly treated. He's hanged.
然后你开始看到这种奇怪的亚瑟王式的传说——实际上他被藏起来了，他在等待着归来。正是这种幻想支撑着在西班牙统治下的葡萄牙人。但我仍然认为，葡萄牙人本有可能接受西班牙的统治，除了17世纪发生的事情——基本上就是第一次世界大战。我想我们应该在这里休息一下，明天带着新的一集回来，我们将从“第一次世界大战”开始。那么我们到时候见。到时候见。再见。阿迪奥斯（Adiós）。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。
But isn't the one who doesn't speak Portuguese at all? Yeah, he's from Naples. He doesn't speak – So – Yeah. I think that's pushing – It's very Perkin, Warbeck, and Lambert Simnel, isn't it? But basically, it becomes clear that he is dead,
有关独家节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和少许八卦的固定来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
and so then you start to get these kind of weird King Arthur-type that actually he is hidden away, and he's waiting to come back. And this is a fantasy that sustains the Portuguese under Spanish rule. But I still think it's possible that Portugal might have accepted Spanish rule, except for what happens in the 17th century, which is basically the First World War. And I think that we should take a break here, come back tomorrow with a further episode, and we will begin with the First World War. So we will see you then. See you then. Goodbye. Adios. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
如需收听加长节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想无广告收听、获取加长节目以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。